what i hope to do in this video is even
more examples to make sure we really
understand how various things would be
accounted for in the expenditure
approach to gdp now we have talked about
this in other videos there's many
different ways of calculating gdp but in
the expenditure approach you can break
it down as being made up of consumption
by households plus investment by firms
plus government spending on goods and
services by the government and net
exports and so with that out of the way
pause this video and look at each of
these statements and think about what
effect would it have on gdp if we have
the expenditure approach and how would
it be accounted for in these various
categories
okay now let's work through this
together so this first scenario it says
ford pays 1 million dollars for a
us-made robot for its factory in
california
so we have a firm right over here it is
ford and it's investing in physical
capital and in most cases especially if
you're looking at some type of a
standardized test on an ap exam
investment is firms investing in
physical capital although it can also be
on intellectual capital things like
software but this is very clear it's
ford buying a us-made robot physical
capital this robot is going to help ford
make more cars or trucks whatever it's
trying to make so this is a very clear
that it would increase gdb so gdp
would go up by one million dollars
because of this
one million dollars and the place that
it would be accounted for is in
investment so i could say investment
would go up one million dollars or the
reason why gdp goes up one million
dollars or you would add one million
dollars to gdp is because you would add
one million dollars to investment this
is a clear investment by a u.s firm all
right now let's look at the next
scenario a u.s car rental company spends
1 million dollars to buy 30 new fords
that were made in the u.s
so pause this video again see if you can
think of that
well this is a very similar scenario a
u.s car rental company and it is
investing in physical capital right over
here by buying those 30 new fords it can
rent those out to create future benefit
and so once again it would be the same
thing in that first case gdp would be
would go up by a million because
investment goes up by a million and in
this case as well gdp would go up by a
million dollars because investment went
up by a million dollars
now let's look at this third scenario a
u.s car rental company spends 1 million
dollars to buy 30 new toyotas that were
made in japan
so how is this different
well in this scenario you still would
have a u.s firm investing in physical
capital spending a million dollars so
you actually would you would actually
have investment go up by one million
dollars but it's not investing on in
things that aren't made in the united
states it's investing in things that are
made in japan so in this particular
scenario it will be counteracted by net
exports
here we are importing a million dollars
worth of things and so that would take
net exports so net exports would go down
by one million dollars a one million
dollar import is the same thing as a
negative one million dollar net export
and sen and so because of these two this
will have no impact on gdp no
impact
on
gdp and the reason why this makes
intuitive sense is remember gdp is
supposed to
measure how much a
how much was produced
and in this scenario a car rental
company is investing but it was produced
someplace else it wasn't produced in the
united states
now this third scenario a japanese car
rental company spends one million
dollars to buy 30 new fords that were
made in the united states so this is
almost a symmetrically opposite scenario
so we would not add to investment here
because this was a japanese car rental
company and we're calculating gdp for
the united states or at least that's the
assumption
but because the u.s would export these
30 new fords four million dollars that
would add to net exports so in this case
net exports let me do the net export
color
net
exports would go up by
1 million dollars and because net
exports went up by 1 million dollars and
nothing else here is impacted gdp
gdp would go up by one million dollars
and once again the reason why this makes
sense is the united states produced one
million dollars worth of stuff it
happened to export them out and that's
where it got accounted for but
definitely gdp is one million dollars
higher because of this
so this next one is interesting you buy
a hundred thousand dollars of ibm stock
what do you think this is pause this
video again
so you in traditional language you might
say i invested a hundred thousand
dollars of ibm stock but i'm a household
so how does this work well it turns out
that this does not move any of these
dials right over here because at least
the assumption here is that you are
buying that hundred thousand dollars of
ibm stock from someone else it is not it
is not because something is being made
in the united states there's some new
productivity that's happening and so
even though in everyday language we
sometimes think of this as an investment
this has no impact on any of these
categories so no
no impact and i really want to emphasize
that
investment is sometimes associated with
things like buying stocks but investment
in the gdp sense is when a firm is
buying some type of of capital that'll
give it some future benefit help it make
things better
oftentimes it's physical capital more
and more it's often things like software
or or some type of intellectual capital
microsoft buys 100 million dollars of
ibm stock
this one might be even more tempting to
put in the investment category because
microsoft for sure is a firm and it
looks like it's investing in another
firm but once again microsoft isn't
buying some type of physical machinery
or it isn't buying an accounting system
or some type of intellectual capital
it's just buying shares from someone
else so once again nothing new is being
produced in the country so this has no
impact i really want to emphasize these
last two because this shows up on some
exams where it says oh this kind of
feels like an investment at least in
everyday language so people would
account for it there but remember no new
capital microsoft isn't buying something
that's going to help microsoft produce
more of whatever microsoft is trying to
produce
all right this next one the social
security administration makes a two
thousand dollar payment to a retiree
what do you think is going on there
so you might be tempted to say hey
that's a government expenditure the
social security administration they're
spending two thousand dollars but we
have to remind ourselves this g category
is government expenditure on goods and
services not a transfer payment like
this and so this would have no
no impact another intuitive way to think
about it and we've been talking about
this for a while
nothing new is being produced in the
united states because of this payment
now we can contrast that with the next
scenario right over here
the social security administration buys
a new accounting system well in this
scenario the government is buying a good
or service it might be a combination of
both they might have to buy some
computers some software maybe hire some
consultants to implement it for them so
it is the government paying for goods
and services so in this situation our
government category would go up by
however much they're spending let's say
they spent let's say this was i don't
know one million dollars again so then
the government would
the government category would go up by
one million dollars because it's a good
or services spending and because of that
gdp would go up by
one million dollars hopefully you
enjoyed that